can heat used with a castor oil pass caused constipation? No, I don't think so. No, I mean,
anything could cause anything, I guess, but pretty much probably not. Can castor oil pack be used
on little P breasts? I don't know. If you're just talking about fibrocystic breast disease using a
castor oil pack, I don't know. When you put castor oil on your skin, you will absorb some of it.
I don't think I would do castor oil packs on fibrocystic breast. No, I wouldn't do that. I certainly
wouldn't do it over a breast tumor as well. Dim metabolize, I think this means can't. Will dim
metabolize good astrogens or just bad astrogens? It can metabolize both. I don't think it's specific
just to the four hydroxyesteroids. I think it can help get rid of all astrogens, which isn't a bad
thing because other astrogens are precursor tumor for hydroxyesteroids. So I think it will reduce
all of it. Again, not anything like, you know, taking a medical drug will not taste inhibitor,
but it certainly will reduce the total astrogens.